welcome everybody to the h3 podcast I'm
Ethan from a station productions joined
with us today is markiplier the legend
oh no about that one you are kind of a
legend on YouTube my friend and with us
as well as Ian from Smosh another legend
titans of the industry who heightened
the motor are you feeling how are you
feeling about all this like praise I
don't know man
it doesn't two legends came together
yeah come on to discuss undos let me
just do a brief watch and about yeah
exactly
I like that trend thought to you by this
episode's brought to you by me on DS
com4 /h 3 great underwear soft as heck
more about that later
sorry mark I had to do they make me do
that they're like that off cutoff we get
show the packaging here can I don't know
100 want to talk about it now it seems
like sure yeah I love a good pair of
underwear let's talk about it I look
good yes I'll tell you what Oh wherever
you're gonna love this cool okay now I'm
not even kidding
people like goddamn oh where are you
wearing some right now I'm not wearing
it now oh I didn't want you guys they
listen they sent me one pair I don't
want to give you one that I've worn
that's fair right ah be an honor
privilege so give that a squeeze and
tell me that's not soft that's nice that
is like impressively soft and it's
Wonderbread patterned they made out of
silk it's a micro farad off mode all
this is me jokingly I freaking love what
else is no dollar use this mode all is
in my bedsheets and it was so there you
go get it guys you're getting
I do have I do have a pair of me undies
and Wow oh wow are there no rails on
yours off you gonna cut that guy and
we're here with ela of course yeah who's
got man spreaded out of existence yet we
care about that and we'll fix it in the
future we'll get another camera so we
currently only have a switcher with four
spots so we can't actually include ela
we're fixing you so we're on it
when we have to guess regardless are you
guys doing today thank you so much for
coming out joining us marking in I
appreciate you guys so much
what's that you done oh well we talked
about everything before like in like I
was offline where do we begin I just
came off of a two days there's charity
livestreams yes yeah totaling 12 hours
about $200,000 donated to game-changer
which was really cool and no no I'm here
it's all been a blur I'm like I'm like
wasted on sleep and I have no idea where
I am but it's been really cool yeah dude
I caught that livestream so you guys are
selling like pajama pants to raise money
for for the charity yeah and how many
pairs did you guys flank I forget what
the exact number was it was last time I
checked it was 11,500 Wow
whoa whoa so what we do is like on the
streams we sell various like shirts and
one up because I always like the idea of
people buying something and they are
buying something they get a cool item
and then the proceeds go to charity so
yeah I've done this for like God I've
done it for like 50 chiri stream so now
tana know maybe 30 but i've never made a
penny off of it so yeah you did so many
of the charities transics christian try
to do it once a month whenever I can but
uh what a lot of charity you guys were
supporting game-changer what is that
it's an organization that basically
provides a better quality of life for
for people that are in the hospitals
usually younger like kids and some like
there's the various child charities like
child's play and obviously obviously
Make A Wish Foundation and but this one
was special because when my buddy Tyler
first came to
la he's an old friend of mine that is
from Cincinnati with me he moved here
and then one of the first bonding
experience that we had while we were out
here was going down to this event down
in data point where the founder of this
organization his son had been battling
leukemia for five years five years
hard-fought battle and now he's on for
some cancer-free and he's out of that
and he founded this organization that
just basically helps anyone who's in the
situation like that anyone can find more
information about it on the website
place is really cool I've noticed that
you particularly I haven't done any
charity [ __ ] I'm just a comic shut up
piece of [ __ ] my she did okay I don't
know we've talked about it I want to do
it yeah I wanted to talking about it
last night because talking about your
strength I said whenever hit you up way
share a last wishes give me my hat that
last wish they're not all about it is
make a wish
yeah but there's those kids that are on
the recovery chanson might be the last
wish another but you don't think about
that well that's why no trauma not be
invited it's like it all makes sense
it's important it is important to off
sorry I was just trying to defend here
hella good but you can send you for one
second leave like it is important to
sometimes recognize that it sometimes it
is it is kids last which again sometimes
is important to record right but always
you definitely don't want to mention oh
there last week yeah when you show up
you know so this is it huh this is your
last wave right right but wait how many
make a wishes have you guys got how many
how many dying children made their last
final wish on this earth to meet you
guys I think I think we've done really
five five yeah something like that like
you like calf Smosh and then half Smosh
games so are they ever like I just want
Anthony yes yeah they always just after
Anthony no there is there's what did you
is one thing it wasn't it wasn't for
make-a-wish it was for I think it was a
local local organization in Detroit
called Rainbow Connection
there's a girl she was battling cancer
and she we went there we surprised her
there in Detroit and she definitely
liked Anthony a lot more like you that
like like when when we like showed up
she like went straight for Anthony and
definitely paid a lot more attention
like then I was like other great but
it's like it's like cool
you're you do your thing Yeah right I
don't know I have to emphasize the
children dying part but okay is your
show me I mean why you want as long as
you don't say it like when when I'm when
I'm here for it may go guys I don't
think it will ever happen I just don't
think I just don't think so you've had a
quite a bit how many of you had uh
probably 30 oh I'm doing charities
you're saving to get in lining up and
you're just like all right beautiful
people but a five minute well in a way
like that sometimes happens at
conventions like these families they
come for like like a group things where
they come over to a convention they get
a full VIP access to all the facilities
and whatnot and I try to get them in as
much as possible and we get like 30
minutes per family and I feel so bad on
the rushing but yeah and then the
weirdest thing happened last year I I
was given the make-a-wish Foundation
celebrity of the Year award your
competition with like the rock man other
to the rock clearly doesn't care
compared to Mars yeah john cena is
nowhere near on my level john cena
currently holds like the record for the
most mega wishes as he's got like 580
like john doe yeah oh yeah he's like
incredible with that stuff Wow like I'm
just honoured about it like just really
I am that is honestly a better than made
that is genuinely like God bless you did
yeah I just I didn't like it was so
weird being there just because I I'm not
trying to sound like overly humble and
I'm not trying to blow my own horn here
but like it was just weird to actually
have people like recognize you for
something that this seemed like a course
of course a kid once seen me like well
there's oh there's yeah yeah absolutely
it's a weird situation yeah because it's
like because you do get that feeling
where it's
like you you realize you could have like
gone to Disney World or something like
but you chose to come here and eat pizza
with us yeah it's gonna be like a weird
Facebook there's just so many emotions
involved of like I'm going and just
being confronted with a child who's like
faced with death yeah I almost I'm when
it's not just it's not just an impact
for the kid but also the parents like we
had like I'm sure you've you've had the
same thing with a parents like this is
the first time like you know he's smiled
and so long and like they're taking my
heart Wow yeah it's pretty the cry I
remember like those exact words or
exactly what my hands will say to you
and like sounds heart-wrenching it is
totally cool art it's a really cool
place it's just like it's like a day of
emotions in that room and it's it's
something that I could never like
replicate just by talking to you but if
you ever get the chance and I'm sure you
guys there's some kid out there waiting
to die and call me up if you want to put
it by anything kids out there give me a
holler boy Wow
how about that anything else talk about
it work I mean that was fascinating I
didn't mean to bring it all heavy on
here oh yeah like I went really fast
it's gonna be like the cry stream like
well going to be like yeah no no I mean
is anything else at a time when you're
suggesting sorry again it's always
saying maybe it's the phone intemperance
you want to like move it away okay we go
out on airplane mode right straight
airplane mode that [ __ ] but it does that
help oh oh should I ever cry mom I mean
I don't yeah that was that hey guys
welcome where an airplane mode we're
troubleshooting some music fan some
noise any dying kids out there give me a
ring you can reach me at work with h3 at
gmail now I'm going to get it back no
but I mean you know yeah no I I thought
we go everybody say in this mode just so
anything else had to talk about you guys
seen Pratt Saving Private Ryan
that's a pretty sad movie yeah yeah sure
I mean hopeful in a way yeah right
actually no not at all bad yes all I
felt like dampeners yeah I felt like the
message of that movie was life is
suffering thank you very much
how about that twist though at the
ending I mean I don't spoil it since
it's a new movie but yeah
quiet Widow buddy now what else you go
what's going on with you lately what are
you working on uh you know just just the
huge you know justjust writing
performing sketches I was on I was on
markup Liars I don't I just call you
working here you don't call glad that
was weird I wasn't calling me Marc
Spector that's the one I usually you
just call you that guy you have a what
up guy yeah yeah I know the Marx stream
yesterday so I came in for a little bit
and we just played some games played
some worms College I'm getting yeah is
actually the new one called WMD like
worms WMD is super cool is it good I
used to play warms a lot well so
Armageddon was the [ __ ] oh and then and
then they like kind of went like they
tried to get too creative with a 3d yeah
I mean all garbage this year was one is
actually just back to 2d and every night
is super nice
yeah you guys are both gamers yes yeah I
used to be I used to be like a pretty
hardcore gamer back in the day
please play EverQuest you guys ever
heard member that oh damn did you grind
that that [ __ ] no no I heard of it you
know the game didn't play okay it's like
pretty Wow yeah that was the first MMO
and that pretty much stole my entire
childhood I played that game for
collectively like 2,000 hours between
the age of like 13 to 16 nice it was all
I did and let me tell you what I don't
regret it
ya know it's the best time some quality
quality mm oh I feel like these days
it's harder for me to enjoy video games
because you guys feel that maybe yeah I
think it's a time issue like like back
when you put EverQuest you had all this
free time because you were a kid or
whatever is that all of it but like then
as you get older and you have actual
real responsibilities suddenly your time
is precious and you're like you know I
can't play an MMO I can't absolutely 60
hours a week to this game I definitely
feel like there is a direct correlation
between free time
enjoyment of video games but I missed
that you know yeah like that back in the
day playing video games you'd have [ __ ]
to do no those were the best days and
also you are the board hump wishing much
yeah that is a factor because I I was
the same way are you telling me I didn't
accomplish anything Doug yeah I had like
straight-up dragon loot and oh I mean I
was deaf everyone knew me I everyone in
your clan I was like whatever
as a fellow person in World of Warcraft
who at all tier 1 through tier 4 like
set-pieces valuating hell yeah I put
like three hundred and sixty four hours
four days into the game like just my my
time in the game was almost quantified
in years of in-game time yeah yeah and
I'm calling you a big nerd wow that is
your another note oh but that's what I
loved
I had no ambition I had no desire to
accomplish anything and lay out just
that game that's right like waking up in
the morning all I was like I just want
to go play this game and just being
there was like all I need to feel
satisfied it's almost like heroin
because you hear like when people do are
on heroin right the only thing about the
next exactly are everything they do
they're like I wish I wasn't here when
this would be way more fun yeah I I feel
like I had were you and I knew that it
was he done with it but I was a witness
to when he was playing dota right so it
was in pretty big fun dota you know I
was pretty annoying it was like if that
was on like man I know it is like
smoking weed - doing heroin easy kill
but there was a plus side to it because
I ended up drawing all the T was like
I'd opt to spend as much time with them
no no no but it made me draw more but I
was pretty mad because they would just I
hate this game so like you can't leave
the games like I want to I want to go
cook something and there's like no I
have to finish the game for the next
hour yeah dota is pretty annoying like
that is it like super long matches I
never play Attah in terms of like MOBAs
compared to like League or Heroes of
Nazareth what is Adams doing his yeah
yeah Nazareth what does that mean I
figured I like I like weight as I can oh
it sounds like religious like Jesus is
going to bed
like Nazareth that's the city which is
from I play that moba Jesus and Moses
deccan up
why why why is they have all these games
that have like Greek gods and stuff like
that why is Brigadier
I guess 11 would have a little bit of an
issue with that I think but I also is
your right but also is Jesus just Opie
probably hmm if you have some people
probably he's LPS [ __ ] yes God he's the
Holy Trinity he's got the whole shebang
he's got the cheese the triple threat
he's got the song and the dance Jesus
what could you do
[ __ ] the dead Zeus do in the face of
Jesus I wonder what would Jesus his
weapon be in that game kazoos he's got
the Lightning right I was just like
spreads the CEO you like when a good
carpenter right right so he could like
build like a really sick chair you just
sit and just like maybe just like like a
wrestling chair that doesn't seem very
powerful but I like the image of it I
mean if it's Jesus throwing a chair that
could be a pretty powerful throw Wow
maybe there's a developer watching
unison great discussion is my favorite
discussion so odd cat somehow whenever
we have this podcaster it always comes
back at some weird way to religion
terrific to the topic at hand
um you play video games for a living so
how do you well I guess it's different
when you're doing it for work right
because you're like fulfills both of
those needs you know it doesn't so what
is it today it's it's a tragedy the last
game that I've really had time to
dedicate to was Mass Effect Andromeda
and I was such a disappointment anyway
like I wasted my time in the first place
and the last time I really played a game
for fun was probably like a year ago
what was it okay overwatch yes when I
played overall difference came out
played a lot so when you decide on what
game to play it was that process like
and you just don't enjoy the game as it
just feel like work no I mean there's
some enjoyment to it the thing about
doing Let's Plays as a living is uh it
it becomes very much a need versus want
kind of thing like I want to play games
that make me like enjoy them but there's
also a need to play games that are fresh
and let people write really popular
right now
right may not even be good but they're
good for performance you know
right and so there's a fine line to walk
I try not to make videos that I don't
personally enjoy and yet I and every
other less player in the world cannot
say that they have had the best time
when they've been playing games when a
flat-out lie
and be I would be I would be the worst
kind of person if I said that but I
still find joy out of it like by
branching off of games you know doing
sketches yeah you've been branching out
a leap again yeah I love it
like I love it and the people seem to
love it too I just wish it was easier to
do like oh yeah you guys obviously know
and you obviously know like from a
lifetime of doing it yeah you use a lot
of work yeah I automatically I'm and
I've always been I think a lot of the
reason why other youtubers hate let's
players is because it's like you just
kind of jealous yeah because it's just
relatively like easy yeah and like
really I mean relatively anyway I don't
even know if it is but in your mind
you're like oh look at this guy he
records himself he puts them up
he gets million two million views and
then you know I don't know if it's true
or not more efficient yet would be the
better yeah yeah and and it is a little
easy like depending on who you are of
course but it is anybody you do you do
two videos a day right yeah and I can
display them today right what are you
doing man dragon off in the corner you
know he'll you let it yes it I'll try it
they never see my webcam from the waist
down
mark this backside in a little corner
jerking off yes that's a sim waiting to
come out to add that here list of nice
already made mark checking out for the
corner simulator I would be a lay bet
that somebody has something like that
many a body pillow has been amazing
people [ __ ] mark player body pillows I
hope have you checked any title 34
recently no but a new find mark player
body pillows came in weird yeah you have
the ivory thing man
you have everything I don't body pills
people want to [ __ ] anything you have
kids who are dying they're literally
about to die like I said my kids that
you have biceps
yeah yeah yeah look at me and let's look
at you
[Laughter]
it's just like Marc's dick podcast
please tell me about you what's going
what's a what what is this what is no no
it yeah how did you easier continue
after what I choose well I don't know
because I don't have biceps yeah what
are you asking no question well that is
just okay let's have a look at
markiplier body pillows that is just
honestly I feel like I've never even
said wow there's a cuff oh no those are
a keychain ones so they're just melody
just so you like just caress it in your
here I see a dandy sex penguin just to
the right I mean if you go scroll up a
bit
I see if whenever we can show it I think
that's Danny's ex bang oh my goodness it
oh my goodness with the hairy chest
clicker is that considered not yeah
there's no probably not probably fitted
Oh while the wait wait doctor there's
that Lea furry Oh how does that make you
feel
no make you feel desired or real I'm
creeped I to each their own like as long
as it don't try to shove it in my face
like whatever I don't care that's the
thing that's like because obviously you
have you have fan fictions that are
written about I'm assuming you and and
Tyler oh they're ever that you're with
yeah and it's like click that check
Jason I don't thank you let's just let's
just keep the jacksepticeye wonderful
brain bad views are gonna sky right yeah
this is it's like it's like okay like
you know fanfiction like it's not for me
but if this is your head about 'let then
then how about it
have you read gotten deep into the
fanfare yeah have you I know we're not I
telling you I have nothing that you have
it's fascinating how many words they can
come up with for dick oh yeah oh yeah
and it's also fascinating how many pages
they can write sometimes there's entire
novels with you guys fanfiction with um
and oh yeah
that's got to be a really hot exchange
so I'm not as it gets pretty it gets
pretty steamy but there's there's one
that like we've we did a couple videos
where we where we read them and there's
one that like we've tried
read but it's so insanely graphic
impossible to get through it like home I
feel like I've a pretty good stomach for
that kind of stuff but it's like there's
milk involved oh wow the creosote or
your milk like yeah just like yeah I
think some some milk you buy at a
supermarket involved in sexual act yeah
I goes into places where milk doesn't
normally go into how that doesn't narrow
it down
your butthole milk in the button here
yeah yeah some orifices for sure milk in
the butt yeah you can talk about it here
specifics it'll fit into this well I
mean if you really want you could pull
up the fit but I would not suggest it it
gets any gums I did enjoy your recent
work
oh that okay I don't think I got that
far but I can assume that that probably
happened okay cool
that takes like to get something in the
urethra is like a pretty takes a good
guess I wonder if in the writing to like
and then they sat down and strategize
they go out to themselves how can we get
this milk in the urethra as a man who
have had three qualities all Tobel
catheters it's surprisingly easy like
really rising lee have you guys seen
sometimes I've seen pictures okay I
haven't gotten to do DME paint Olympics
is that wasn't but I heard his fake by
the way be me my heart yeah what
it's just video because I don't know
it's like been around forever and I'd
yet everyone kid was trauma have you
seen this on the toilet the one where
he's cutting off his dick it's a
compilation uh-oh I never complained
Olympics and it's a compilation of all
these guys just shopping their guts off
and they're castrated really did like
real feel it looks so real but I heard
it's fake but I wonder if people just
told me that to make me feel better
because I feel better knowing that it's
fake but I want to believe I want to
believe that it's that it's not real
just for my own sanity I've heard that
it's fake and that help that helps me
sleep at night yeah but anyway I've seen
pictures like dudes are into it when you
let shove stuff into the resounding
sounding what some are like I know they
should buy I know about it's called
sound wait why is it called sounding
I do not know but I know that it's
called sounding when you shove things in
your urethra for pleasure because you
probably make a weird sound when it
happens yeah what he supposed to sound
like no I haven't done it
cut your the catheter guy yeah then for
blood because I had a tumor removal
janitors later martyrs at home standing
in the corner today did they knock you
out for that or is it just like you're
gonna brace for this no I thankfully I
was out when they put it in but I was
awake when they pulled it out so uh and
like how deep does it go can i manly
curious for me it's ready yeah really I
a vet bladder because when they pull it
out like is it like a nice like it lasts
for a minute where it's like you know
yeah it's all the way up into your
bladder wow I gotta go down I gotta lie
down here I mean
oh you let's got us some some hot
updates on Sunday which sound o shah-i
was talking about john stinks Oh Shawn
stinks god bless him Shawn from our old
videos oh I know that reminds me have
something exciting to tell you we got
the outfit Oh Shawn said urethral
sounding is the medical use of probes
called sounds to increase the inner
diameter of the urethra and to locate
obstructions in it let's go Wow well
here's the plus side to sound these bars
and I'm talking you specific because I
know you're into this kind of thing
Thanks
if you ever get flattered what is it
called kidney stones yeah no kidney
stones are no problem when you sound
no no it's bad oh it doesn't help well
cuz the pain the pain is I thought it
was in your dick
well yeah it hurts that's when you're
passing it but the real pain is between
your kidneys and your bladders in this
little tube called the ureter and you
have you had kidney stones yeah well
okay this is fascinating and it was like
during a shoot - yeah you did you finish
the shoot
no go on the whole time I was like oh
shoot I was like guys there's like a
weird like kink in my back and like I
was like trying to like pop my back it's
like it's getting worse I don't know I
thought like maybe I had to like take a
[ __ ] or something so
I was like I was like sitting around I
was like I don't know like I was
sweating I was like turning pale and our
director thought that I was like I was
like just being a little whiny right
person and then like I was like I was
like I don't know guys I don't think I
think finishes I think I need to go to
hospital and like and so they get one of
our friends like pull the car up and I
take like one step in the car and I just
[ __ ] row oh he's like it's like okay
no you're actually in pain you must have
been like if at the time you don't know
what it is you must have been really
freaked out
well I was like I was read I was on -
you know it's WebMD a guy symptoms I was
like I think it might be kidney stones
because it's like this terrible pain
like a kind of like it's like not quite
like where your spine is it's like you
know Murray kidneys are yeah and and so
yeah it was it was the worst pain I
don't wish it on any of my enemies so
walk me through that how long did that
last
oh well so I went to the ER and of
course it was busy so I had to wait
either like wait in the waiting your
whole time the pain doesn't subside it
does not and there's no way you can dole
the pain either it's just you just have
to sit there and just bear it and then
they took me in triage and then gave me
something and then it was like no pain
so I think they gave me some like just
some good [ __ ] some harder this year and
then I threw up again in in a sink and
then and then they gave me some percocet
and her good sex could you know and then
I was and then I was okay but it was
wobble so that is actually one of my
worst fears is getting a kidney stone -
yeah I hear about it every time I and
it's like every time I feel I'm really
terrified about anyone every time I feel
a slight pain of a comic book not again
like I freaked out and so you had this
horrible pain how long were you in the
ER uh until I got treatment like an hour
maybe but did you but how do you treat
that because you just oh they like zap
it with ultrasounds right if it's big
enough mine wasn't big enough to warrant
like doing the ultrasound thing so they
did like a cat scan and
and then yeah they just gave me some
some good drugs could drugs and then set
me on my way and they're like well you
pass it eventually I guess at some point
it broke up and I packed it but and you
didn't know like you couldn't you didn't
feel it happening I know no it's really
weird I think I think it broke up at
some point but some people they they
feel it on the way out
see that's what I've heard yeah I
remember one of my good friends growing
up he says dad has regular kidney stones
and he would hear him in the bathroom on
a somewhat regular basis screaming and
pain yeah and this is a guy who's like
been through war like this is a guy
who's seen [ __ ] they actually terrified
me that story
yeah they equate it to giving birth on
like a pain I kind of doubt that pill
wait just wait I didn't through some I
haven't Albert I haven't I haven't given
birth to a child well I've been through
extreme pain and I still probably
wouldn't equate it to job well yeah
extreme pain I've been through a few
things but the top-ranking pain was
after I got out of my surgery for my
tumor removal they split me down from
the front and then they had to scoop out
my intestines and I loved the skill yeah
the scoop is what really did it but they
had to get it on my adrenal gland in the
left one so they I just don't have an
adrenal gland down there but you take
supplements for that no I'm fine I don't
have to take any medication you need an
adrenal gland no my right one is like
yeah receiver also you still get Stoke
yeah oh god right now yeah but so after
that I had an epidural to numb the pain
and I was helping at first but it was
making my legs numb which is very bad in
an epidural they had to change up the
medication to have less anesthetic more
painkiller what they ended up doing was
less anesthetic and no painkiller
so for pain 24 hours yay yay I went
post-op right after my abdomen was split
with no painkiller
no I was in that is over I would they do
that to you well because they thought
that they increased it anyway the
pharmacy in the husband
that wrong um so like a full day I kept
going to my nursing like this is really
bad can you please not do this sling and
like she believed me but the doctor came
in multiple times and just grabbed on my
wound and just like feeling for bleeding
it was like he didn't believe me he
didn't believe that I was in pain and
I've been through I've gotten
second-degree burns on my hands I have
had my intestine cinched off and like
had an intestinal blockage I've broken
both bones of my arm all those pain I
would do that again any day you never
would I do that
voluntarily do that pain again yeah that
long that's a nightmare and even that I
would not equate to childbirth well that
girl hurts like crazy too right no
that's another time well I was like a
shot straight in your spine yeah but it
didn't drip into your spine it's not a
shot okay I had this other thing though
where they had to when they had to get a
biopsy of the of the tumor I know oh
they had to do a biopsy so I was in a
cat scan and I was awake very little
painkiller the end this guide to start
stabbing this this medical tool into my
back right into my adrenal gland and
just was like all right you're a brave
man they do hold out a piece but like
just I felt like I was getting stabbed
slowly it was all good I stub my toe
this morning I was hard I actually have
never been through like X you guys are
missing some [ __ ] that's it otherwise
I've led a pretty sheltered life yeah
you busy you've seen [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I said I like I still know that
there's people that have seen more [ __ ]
so I'm like I'll take the [ __ ] I've been
through and the pregnancy is frankly
horrifying like I I am so thankful and
this is like giving respect to women no
like no it is I'm so thankful because I
know it's like a horrible thing that
wouldn't have to go through but it must
be horrible to confront that and I'm so
happy you had your sound no but you have
to I mean I'm grateful yeah I don't know
how to describe it's like thank God I'm
not you well it's kind of dope that I
don't have to [ __ ] out a baby let's be
honest
kind of true but at this but and by
acknowledging that I'm saying God bless
you
right right we should all yeah Thank You
illa thank you thank you thank you
congratulations there is like a machine
that is supposed to simulate the pain oh
that sounds great
ban me up electrodes on your stomach and
it'll cramp everything up and you'll see
it is going to make me do that now but
that does it but I really go I don't
think the key I want you to do is while
she says that oh oh yeah it can't be
here we get a shot of Ian's doing that
motion just that part yeah well I've
heard [ __ ] like that that the holes okay
they're like friends no they fuse let's
go back to videos by magically they're
magically few they get there and they
have to get pitched up like men to me
that's fascinating because it's just so
poor fine well also don't you normally
like we're done we're still tie my
pregnancy right okay yeah yeah don't you
normally I hear a lot of times when they
give birth they also [ __ ] yep yeah if
you remember job 12 hours I got into
that dumb son is that in no way is it
just like oh I have to [ __ ] so I'm gonna
[ __ ] myself when you're waiting out a
play we're not give you everything yeah
and it's all just a man I've heard that
there's like there's nurses who are on
like [ __ ] duty and they just scoop it up
real quick and you're like that was hey
nobody gonna notice they just they have
a code word that they do to growl down
and drop down come with a code Brown
tide change of topic
the healers scare no ela maybe we should
just keep talking about pregnancy I'm on
the side of he landings oh man I talk
about yeah yeah you have a you have a
really good painful story that horrifies
me that I think fascinating about my
wisdom to you oh it was more like just
traumatizing than the pain because I had
my all my wisdom teeth removed and
bracket yeah and is Rico so that they
well grind like sideways instead of up
they're going sideways I was really yeah
for you slackers
I didn't get mine out oh wow I thought
that was like routine adieu when you
were my brother got it I didn't tell me
my future well I'll tell there's a easy
fix that they don't do in Israel yeah I
did my procedure in Israel so apparently
in Israel they don't put you under under
anesthesia so they just do a local kind
of thing where they just numb this area
but you're completely awake and I was
completely aware of everything and you
just the doctor first of all was very
like aggressive not like a gentle dude
and he just cracked the suit and I don't
know why it was just so horrifying for
me I just yes I like just traumatized
and I was just crying the way you
described it it's like they're in there
and they're you can see because you're
not there guys although right it's like
you're breaking yeah yeah but you're
you're numb to the paint but you can
feel the crying and the kinda noises
right oh god this is our family I have
my wisdom teeth out they put me to sleep
I woke up I said good night moon god
bless america
put it on click eight so vicodin had a
nap I was like yeah when Ethan told me
that I was like what
that's not bad a lot of a lot of them
don't and a lot of them say that that
anesthesia is just a way for the oral
surgeons to get more money out of you
after hearing you yeah yeah any I want
to be put under for sure and also I was
I needed to do all four of them and the
guy was like just do it now and I was
like I was crying like hysterically I
was like no I'm going home people and
okay Daniel and then I just I came back
four times to do each one separately go
holy crap I didn't I did four times oh
yeah God is like can you measure they
were like through my life seriously I
didn't know you did it four times that's
horrifying but honestly it's not that
Rob you guys yeah that was just well
yeah Rosie oh just wait for peg
nighty-night I did try it I would try
one just to see what it was like not to
like show you up I'm not trying to area
but identically wanted
I am yeah I throw myself into things and
I just love trying new things and even
if they're terrible like on Felix's show
like scare PewDiePie do like I had the
best of cases yeah I heard about it I
was on that oh yeah you yeah oh yeah I
remember you of course you told you well
I had a pig testicle and I know that's
never gonna do that oh yeah so how was
that important I heard joy though it was
very dry the problem was like I would
have been fine if it was like a nice
moist Pig test no but I dream alone dry
and room temperature and just you know I
had no drink with it you know I had to
choke it down milk yeah dusty a little
dusty yeah a little dusty it's funny
seelix was telling me the story about
scare PewDiePie season 2 and he was like
in our episode he lost and he had to eat
like a pig brain or something it was
frankly very anticlimactic but
regardless he's like I told the
producers the one thing I told him going
to season 2 was I don't want to eat
anything weird and they're like ok ok
for sure and then like the ending of
every episode was him eating something
horribly weird yeah how many times do
you lose he lost my episode yeah it was
like out of like so I'll just rate of
say those producers were [ __ ] like
they were oh I'm glad yeah we could talk
about that yeah I'm not gonna work well
I don't I don't think Felix cares about
him I think they've ditched a show they
were kind of like our surprise man
didn't seem very professional operation
no not at all well it's also I think
it's also a lot of like a lot of those
producers come from like TV and they
ended like that I made in the race
yeah and then they and then they're like
oh I'm doing this digital thing yep that
was the other good yeah and it's very
much like and we've had that similar
like stuff before where I like people
are like I got better things to do you
know I'm just not going to put my effort
in some low character [ __ ] yeah it's
weird it's weird especially like even
with like department stuff like if it's
like not like because you know on
YouTube like we our hands are in so many
things and it's like oh that lights
wrong I'm gonna go fix that light or
whatever but
like in LA and in this business is like
oh that's not my department
yeah I gotta remind you I was doing the
episode with Felix on scare PewDiePie to
shoot until there was a scene I was
stuck on a roof they were setting up
these shots I was up there for like two
hours while they're getting ready that's
fine
I had an earwig in my ear which is if
you guys don't know it's a wireless ear
mic so that the producer is gonna be
like hey do this right and I was
standing up there in the earwigs stopped
working it was getting staticky so I had
to take it out it didn't come out I
couldn't get this year wig out of my ear
and I started panic I was freaking out I
was up on this roof nobody was up there
I couldn't talk to anyone they're
setting up and I'm trying to dig this
earwig out of my ear and it's going in
deeper it starts to hurt it feels like
it's bleeding I'm like legitimately
freaking out and I'm like [ __ ] it I need
to say something because they were about
to roll after like 2 or 3 hours of setup
I'm like I don't want to ruin this shoot
but I'm panicking so these guys
downstairs sitting some up like yell do
can you call a producer I'm having a
panic attack and he and they gave me
their like AAA what'd I just do I just
do the pyrotechnics not my job
yeah yeah and I was like help me I'd
like help me I'm in pain I need help
right now and they're like ah they
literally like what a not my god I was
like what
I was I was also there and I was under
it's in like yeah it was like a little
house it was under wolf and I was inside
and I could hear and I was like so he
lives in this Shack yeah it's a probably
good thing they can say that or CRS said
was [ __ ]
but it regardless messages he goes in
the shack and Felix was going to save me
and I come down on a ladder and I kicked
down the door and saved Yili so it's
just me and her and I'm like ela and I'm
talking to her downstairs in the
building I'm like I'm freaking out what
do I do and I no no I knew this I love
imagine you guys look like in this
random like hut in the middle of nowhere
with nobody around you you guys are
screaming nobody by the way I was last
up yeah i was laughte up and I had
rapport with the sound guy we goofed
around a little bit before I climbed up
to my ultimate demise on top of that
room
and I was started talking to the Mike at
a desperation because I know he can hear
me and I was like please send help I
know you can hear me well yeah I'm
talking to you my only hope nobody came
good maybe your mic never works however
I went up to a match I was like yo what
the [ __ ] dog let me in the trenches do
like a sorry
nobody part about my job I'm not a medic
but I did this shot and then afterwards
I'm like ok so my lawyers on the way I
didn't I didn't say that no but anyway
they had a medic come up and he pulled
it out with tweezers like somebody alien
Medicare so yeah it looked scary the
doubter that was traumatic sketchy that
whole episode was honestly a total train
wreck
yeah I wasn't too happy about my
operation either like I just I was in a
similar situation where I was just set
waiting but I was blindfolded which like
I'm fine oh they did it to us they do
their energy like no reason right I'm
Terry hours yeah you're blindfolded for
three hours yeah three hours in the back
of a van yeah we so they did that to us
that when they finally took off the
blindfold it was like completely
pointless didn't matter I just saw every
alig I was expecting so much more than
this blind for your spending take it off
there's like zombies in the car yeah no
oh yeah you really pointless like
everything could be a Franklin you're
right because you're and then it's
completely not and then they just take
it off and they walk you into the room
they were like you do look at me yeah
yeah yeah yeah could have helped you set
up if you needed any eyes on that yeah
funny but like pretty much the my
problem with that show was like they
have these scenes where they're like
okay all these actors on B's are gonna
chase you pretend like you're scared
yeah I'm like wow that's a weird thing
about like because it was it was kind of
like it was scripted but also reality
yeah and it's that weird thing was like
am I supposed to be acting I thought
they might just be myself
yes I've seen it happen a lot on YouTube
right yep yeah that one zombie show did
you guys see that no yeah I watched a
little piece and I I didn't understand
into the band or how they were no no
that's how it yes it was a fight the
Living Dead yes and like that yeah yep
yeah okay yeah but it was like a weird
semi scripted semi reality contest yes
show a lot of the shows are like that
and it just does not work as a format
for like yesterday's Haunted Mansion one
is the same yeah I mean I've never seen
it I haven't seen any other YouTube read
show which is kind of like that for me
to admit but I just haven't interested
me
yeah no it's completely fair I mean
that's the criticism I would level
against YouTube reddit that they they
they they need to invest and making some
good [ __ ] yeah yeah I think it plus it
takes time
and they don't have they don't have
Netflix I mean it's kinda cuz you like
oh you take owned by Google they should
have money but they don't have like
Netflix money to spend on productions
where it's like Netflix spends like a
hundred million on a shoot yeah that's
true they do that it's like well you
don't need a hundred million to make a
good show ya know but it would help you
get some good writers yeah you don't
need 100 okay a little piece of that but
you're like yeah you're not a good
writer um but I feel like that's where
it's like what I'd like one of these
spaghetti this yeah the production
everything like what I'd love to see on
YouTube red is a house of cards style
show that doesn't have even have a
youtuber in it yeah Linda the the
flagship show yes like the one where
they put all their money in the basket
they like okay let's make this great
they don't have a flagship show yeah I
mean it's a damn shame because they
could they could their own talent on
YouTube there definitely is yeah I just
feel like it's not the right amount of
talent or the right people that are
getting addressed for it for them house
a lot of those people end up just going
to you know TV or Netflix and you're it
is a good point hard did because you
know Miranda just went she went straight
to Netflix and I did I think it did uh
my favor has the camera framed up no we
go off I am now oh oh yeah no yeah like
exactly if that's the show that they
want to make and they want to make it
with like it to be good like you might
as well go to the people that are going
to make it but that's why you choose
wrong they need to they need to like
they need to compete in terms of what
they can offer
I think it comes down to money things
like Netflix just has more Netflix Hulu
they have great teams they have great
people
yes I mean YouTube just starting out but
the content you know somehow like Logan
Paul's and everything too high that's
true in every [ __ ] thing
the Viner did you guys are saying what I
was going to say you say they need so
much money but like for example you
guys's sketches are like they look like
TV yeah what is it with that by the way
I mean they're not cheap either do you
have a hundred million dollars I mean no
but I don't we I never but I mean like
we we spend probably we probably spend
more than what we make in YouTube ad
revenue on our sketches so that million
we have to rely on you know sponsored
content or you know originals or
anything like that to make up but yeah
like we you know it costs a lot to make
big productions and you know especially
for something like like because we did a
YouTube read movie and you know it's it
also comes down like you can say like oh
I mean you made that with you know this
much money like why can't you do that
with the movie it's like well you know a
movie requires you know a month tissue
but then suddenly it's like we only have
the budget for 15 days mmm yeah so we
shot we shot ghost baits in 15 days
that's crazy
yes usually none Wow
what was your schedule like every day
and all day well I mean yes I but I mean
our our shoots are always 12 hour days
anyway but but it was a lot of it was a
lot of fun angling with like okay so I'm
that thing that you wanted to happen
outside that's now also going to take
place here and then we were we were
making cuts we were making the entire
like scene cuts and changes like on the
day to make up for time so there's like
there's a little trouble
yes yeah but you know you can only do so
much with but you know a con it kind of
really sucks that they do that because
then nobody's like oh [ __ ] you to read
like if your end product is destroyed
because of them
everyone's like these guys suck not
YouTube red yeah I mean you just have to
make compromises yeah you're real
professional yeah you know I'm glad you
think that
I'm glad though the ruses that's such a
shame though to hear because of like I
haven't had a chance to do YouTube Road
series but I've been offered like a lot
like a lot I've been offered and I've
turned everything down just because I
wanted to make like I like being in
control and if someone told me I had to
cut a scene out of my sketch the day
that I was doing it I am be livid and I
just lose my [ __ ] over that I yeah not
one dude is like when I when I make
things and like admittedly I mostly do
Let's Plays but when I do sketches like
the most proud thing I'm done lately was
this thing I did called the date with
markiplier yeah that was that was it you
saw it yeah oh yeah that was amazing oh
my blur I got a vision yeah you did yeah
oh that's so cool yeah but those us we
just shot that like on our own with our
own camera with our own equipment like
really impressed mall team I love that
Lea because we had so much passion in it
like it was very YouTube in like the way
it went through but like the production
was I look very high-level yeah yeah I
mean I think I really liked your makeup
lady Thiang is pretty gosh it was pretty
cool yeah cool yeah yeah do you want to
tell a little bit about what it was for
people as a kid it was to choose your
own adventure right yeah yeah for anyone
that I haven't seen in there's probably
a lot of you haven't it was this choose
your own adventure with them we had
about 24 different videos and 10
different endings on it and it was an
ambitious passion project we did for
Valentine's Day we shot it in five days
and we edited it in 36 hours
I won't say the post production quality
was like super high on holidays yeah
that was us that was me
Ethan and Catherine all slaving away I
kind of led but everyone was like doing
that like picking up the pace like just
because I've been doing YouTube longer
and like I'm better with special effects
but like I gotta give credit to cath I
mean they did without it it would have
been impossible about them like and I'm
not trying to make myself sound better
by like but it was just like that's the
level of control I want I want to be an
every step of the production like yeah
pre-planning in the shoes to wreck
and editing that's what I need and with
YouTube red is just like that removal of
control that I write it's hard to like
oh yeah cuz you you're you're playing
with somebody else's money yeah so yeah
I guess today wanted they want to say in
the in the content yeah yeah well when
you begin the negotiations on a project
you should be able to get some idea of
how many days and what's the but you
know everything like is was it a
surprise like did they do what 180 on
you I mean it wasn't no it wasn't really
a surprise we knew that we would have
limited time given the budget but we
just wanted to write the best script
possible and then and then figure out
how to make it work right but then yes
I'm some things just because of you know
as you know with with you know this
podcast like sometimes productions run
behind years of unforeseen technical
they always or maybe like one actor
really sucks and you have to keep doing
more and more takes until you get the
right take all right by yourself is
overrated that base you some nobody
today every take of mine is bad but yeah
honestly I got a tip my beating to you
guys it at Smosh because yeah like I
don't I don't know how you guys achieved
the level of polish like one you guys
have television quality content and I
don't know how you do it
thank you it's crazy I mean we have a we
have a good team I mean the same thing
with you like we have a really good team
of people that we've we've had four I
mean we've had the same director for
probably like seven years now well and
he's like you just gotta find people
that kind of like wardrobes and sets
y-yeah yeah and that's what that's what
I was trying to say it really feels like
I'm watching a show on TV like yeah yeah
I mean like we started out you know with
a webcam and and then we like upgraded
to this really shitty handycam or you
could hear the DV tape winding oh yeah
while you're recording and like we just
wanted to make sure that the content was
always improving like the quality the
sound quality the picture quality acting
which I was I think it got a little
better over the years uh but um yeah
like we're we're really proud of the the
quality of because it's not something
you it is you are saying more of it on
you
tube now but it's still taking some time
and let's sketch comedy is like insanely
hard to do on a on a regular basis and
there's I mean I don't there's not
really many other sketch comedy people
other than like Ryan Higa who's killing
it yes show me is impossible I mean I
like seriously it's so like look at
Sarah Night Live I mean they have so
many [ __ ] episodes and you're funny
people it's just can you make funny
sketches everywhere we're working on on
that week like they're writing sketches
just pretty and say yeah yeah because
it's always relevant so hard to make
funny sketches yeah I agree
and you're going to make how many a week
we do we do two week yeah that's banana
that's crazy
that is straight-up banana we haven't
missed a Friday and like eight years
holy freaking I'm ugh yeah and well we
skipped we skipped one because it was
like had a shooting scene and it was
like the Sandy Hook happened like the
day before
now I'm we're like okay we can't release
this video tomorrow oh well so with him
in so you guys can't you came are you
aware you were ready
hooray it was 10:00 it was that adds
that [ __ ] that bad man
yeah have used to you know we wash that
together right the you know the song
another up in heaven so well we do baby
Taylor where those well I am yeah my
moralizing Sandy Hook oh yeah and
they're up in hand anyway did he give
that money or did he oh I don't even
know I don't know they say probably
didn't make too much money from that
long yeah yeah I didn't follow up on
every bus yeah alright let's take a
quick break
I'm used to loop I'm gonna get some
water
I'm gonna sling some undies mmm and then
we'll come back so okay I so how should
I do this should I just do it real fast
yeah I let's do that
alright is it first time plugging no
well I know congratulation thank you
thank you guys biondi's congratulations
on
Ethan thank you so much all right guys
this is the portion of the show where
I'm going to breed our sponsor who by
the way okay
are we good are we seeing Ethan right
now okay oh you just saw them I saw
David great size
by the way thank you so much to those
who support our show it means so much
and it enables us to keep getting out
here and shaking our dicks and having a
great time and having some laughs
this week's sponsor is me undies elevate
your underwear game to the next level
okay but on the real these are some soft
on these boy okay I need to smell them
have a small Doug oh yeah absolutely
publication beyond easy
these are legitimately the softest
undies I've ever felt it's like a silk
Modell is made from birch trees I don't
like good yet but no I ever since I
found out about model I loved everything
oh my goodness also the women's one can
show that I prefer women yeah this is oh
yeah
Hello Dolly just a little confirm that
doesn't look particularly like women's
underwear that kind of lie this is like
some big beautiful woman right into the
medium that is that is some Wow
you know even your expectations of
women's body sizes of finding I mean I
mean there's a sign of the script that
waist this is a large that's a medium
yeah I like my I like a beautiful like I
like my undies beautiful large
me undies are designed in LA and made
from substantially sourced micro metal
so what is your sustainably sort of
substantive sustainably sourced micro
moto a fabric three times soft see I've
never done copy where I just read it
how's it feel it doesn't feel right good
condition it doesn't because usually
I'll give you a genuine yeah talk about
it right if you say in a different voice
it will feel as me indeed see how that
runner it's like you disguise yourself
you're not the one doing exactly me
undid I'd assigned and helped not see
them say right
I feel like that I listen yeah they'll
stay because I let me tell you about me
undies
they're soft underwear something people
don't think about they don't appreciate
it but it's the first thing you put on
when you wake up and it's the last thing
you take off before you go to bed
feeling you deserves to have a great
soft pair of undies and you can get one
by going to me Indies dot-com for / h3
you get 20% off your first pair by going
to my undies calm for / h3 and here's a
wild thing if you don't like it you can
wear it and send them back your dirty
undies for a full refund
April do you think they just wash them
in the day of the hybrid you wondered
that I hope what happened really but I
feel like they did you like a Superbowl
shirt situation where they send off like
all the returns to a lettered world
country ma yeah I feel like they should
just let you keep it married is some
sort of respect at that point I mean and
there's some poor ladies just handling
all the dirty undies yeah but here's the
thing about me undies uh-huh you don't
return it because you love it it's soft
its fluffy its cuddly it's going to take
care of your boys and your girls pound
it long and it's colorful too small one
I mean it's what I mean how about how
about the brain I didn't return to it I
didn't return mine so our head I will
buy some thank you here that authority
I'm using the link the undies comm / a
spree a tree no Johnny calm for / H 3
just that sorry I'm an answer
so my me just oh I'll go in
post-production remove the last page
yeah all things this guys I really
appreciate our sponsor me undies there
let me see if there's in any other
interesting things here about to say
about them this is the best probably
want like a minute this has gone up for
like 10 minutes yeah yeah give the best
plug this is a come on guys get real
let's see they do undies they're you
know gold shades adventurous patterns
that's not really something going wrong
just underwear mark they also do like
maybe I'm reading more they don't
tell me tell me about it let me look
under one if you're not subscribed
that's okay you can apparently get undie
subscriptions yes great
that's but if you're not subscribed
that's fine because use the Flippen code
that we provided they are flipping on
there they did they're like you know
what yeah it's a really cool guy
he'll definitely flip it that sounds
like a TK you're flipping flacon out of
use at me Indies com4 / h3 you won't
regret it
tell me about it I'm going to be wearing
my pair I wanted you guys to be wearing
your pair help support the show sport
our sponsors we love you we appreciate
you yielding you know chronically and
they also do sweatshirts Wow white
shirts in the same memory rule I want
that they do sure it's muscle tank
oh man alright yeah alright I just they
do all kinds of stuff go on head on over
to me on these calm for such Ashley this
is the greatest ad of all time right
yeah you're welcome you're going on like
15-20 minutes okay I don't think it'll
ever hate it I got more material on the
undies if you guys want to just keep
going yeah
what do you got for like 30 minutes we
got certainly got all of him we're
taking the show on the road they pay you
by the minute right so the whole word
longer we go what is the weight of your
stand-up settings really do me on D I
will be back in five five short minutes
welcome back i sedation podcasts out a
little tinkle and we're ready to go
i have to tell you something our guest
next week is going to blow your mind can
we guess who it is yeah yeah take a
guess Jimmy Fallon well thank God whoa
note down big time turn it down big time
Logan Paul I would low it down yeah
bring Logan Paul in here but like have
the room be like full of colors just
testin be like hey I have a really funny
Logan Paul story my ways I do this
[ __ ] I write I really want to tell
this story okay wait what should we do
first
I'll just feel guess the get is joy
salads
is the only salad is coming our pockets
alright yeah that's really cool I mean
you're gonna common salad
oh boy I'm gonna bring that Caesar I'm
going to bring that ranch I'm gonna
bring some boundaries on my dress yeah
I'm gonna bring it all yeah you never
know what kind of sounds gonna wait for
that yeah it's me fun is he hanging out
here for a while is he moving to LA you
have to look out for him where is he
grape soda he doesn't he's a Jersey boy
oh I think he's in LA for a minute he's
doing some serious film work about how
Muslims are ruining society or something
whatever he's up to I don't know yeah
some really interesting [ __ ] some
fascinating original Joey sells
programming but I thought that I thought
you might appreciate that I I do
appreciate that what do you want say
watch because I thought that you would
appreciate that well because we spoke
and you view and mention that you
watched your solids oh I am yeah the big
salads I'm excited I just remember that
we had a conversation well cuz yeah cuz
I was like I was like have you seen this
shoot I do like dude I'm already making
a video on I was like okay good
which one was it at the time I think it
was the Trump car yeah yeah the trip I
was like did you see that oh maybe we
should hold that oh my god it said it's
like one of the best videos to come out
of the hole last year it's basically he
gets all these black people in a parking
lot I'll just describe it yeah he gets
all these actors black actors he goes to
a bad neighborhood in New York and he
gives them all like weapons and he says
beat the [ __ ] out of this car
it has Trump stickers on it and then he
frames the video like I Trump Trump I
parked a car with Trump stickers in a
black neighborhood and so they all came
and vandalized it but he just had all
these actors do it and he and like the
comments and the reaction to that video
was like explosive like they're all
these alt writers and conservative media
were eating it up like and this whole
like Trump mania about how were victims
whatever well I don't know whatever
about the narrative but his video was
fake and we made a video about it and
there's like a snapchat video that
somebody took from like I got in the
building showing him like orchestrating
the videos oh yeah
I mean it's like a Street Fighter level
all of a sudden he just walked out and
all these black guys were like pipes
just start it's like ridiculous
ridiculous
and I'm like and I saw see I'm like this
[ __ ] is fake and super racist and
everyone was like [ __ ] you Ethan you
know this one the real and I was getting
super angry and frustrated with our
community too or at least those people
in our community and then like three
days later this video surfaced a in
reference of somebody in a high-rise was
filming him coordinating it with these
guys
directing it and oh my goodness that was
that was that wasn't the only video
though because yet another one where
he's like I let the car with the truck
open in a black neighborhood he didn't
like he didn't confess that one being
fake but he just doesn't like black
people he just doesn't like black food
or at least he knows what his audience I
think the first the first video I saw
the first video the first eyelids video
I think I saw was um was trying to
educate people on date rape drugs in
Ellora oh yeah oh yeah so far and he's
like an insider you're not caught up on
the salad man I'd really shame editing
out a lot now it's College he's a
prankster if you didn't go well III seen
your video okay I'm like the majority of
oh yeah there's a lot yeah but that was
like that was like he was like he did
this thing weighs like he's like you
know a lot of people get date raped in
bar so I'm going to show you how to not
get day raised super all yeah and then
he was like he'd sit down next to a
person yeah and then he'd be like wow
look at that thing over there I mean you
drop this like fake pill in their drink
and they're like okay and don't drink
that I put drugs in that yeah and
they're just without his father they're
like why did you do that why did he tell
me what had happened and then he tries
like like the last the last girlfriend
Rita yeah they're like the last girl he
like he does it too and then he's like
don't do that I put drugs in that and
then like he told her this whole thing
and he's like really oh can I get you
number like yeah daffodil
respect for like Oh after like you know
putting fake drugs and somebody's drink
the still last word enough he did you
respect yeah she sent out by the way
it's our break it had all the twists and
turns though of a very classical
dramatic movie yeah I'm so many emotions
there's as many emotions in the first
half of the show like it's a right to
roll mr. ed Oh what was it I was gonna
talk about okay Paul yeah okay you guys
I like me some big ol story this is a
good story yeah this this [ __ ] trip now
so I'm hanging out with some friends
I've never have you guys been in notches
house no no but I'm aware of it okay so
notch if you don't know has the most
expensive house in Los Angeles
he paid eighty million dollars for this
house in Beverly Hills he outbid Beyonce
and jay-z imagine me Beyonce and jay-z
been outbid by this year and we just
goof ball look for him wearing a fedora
yeah anyway he did it
well he sold he sold minecraft like two
billion yeah I'm fine that's best chump
changing God that hold just the notch
phenomenon is always a whole Wild Ride
but that's that's neither here nor there
for now guy man [ __ ] were nice good man
registering I had thing like where he's
like saying like after he got all that
money he's like really lonely it would
it would alienate you direction I've got
other men work yeah you know what me and
you were talking about us say something
interesting people always be like oh
when you get money and success you
change and was like oh you change but
the truth is I feel like the people
around you change more I'd say I was
saying like no one ever talks about the
people around you changing yeah like all
the sign of friends are like trying to
teach you stuff there's a few rap songs
but that that's because age is you know
common issue among among the rap
community that's okay yeah good okay
good I'm glad someone's rappers and
Dutch yeah you know notch is a super
interesting sweet guy and I get that
sense to that he's super isolated but um
so anyway he throws it is part of the
weird thing about it as a throws these
huge extravagant parties okay like and
it's a scene this is what I didn't
expect we rolled up and it's like a
young beautiful someone strolling on MD
in the carpet there
rolling around a cycle it's like a it's
a wild scene there's an open bar there's
like flames is security are enough
cocaine I do not see a mountain of
cocaine
no but there's a bar probably wanted
back rooms I didn't get yeah
no VIP no yeah but but it's like a crazy
party like super high class everyone's
looking good so the funny thing is that
knotch is like a very ordinary guy I
think like on a personal level it's
assumed the wealth change very much
because you have all these really high
fashion scenesters and then knotch rolls
through and like over just lay there
until a polo shirt he's had for 10 years
yeah I wear a fedora respect but the
weird thing is like what what I think is
like why are you having these parties I
don't know
it's kind of like Gatsby then he is
totally rickety let's do that he is D
Great Gatsby read read your literature
kids follow the green or whatever I hope
it's not too much like the Great Dane
yeah yeah yeah
does he what any like I guess he
actually mingle with people it is he did
he kind of stayed himself like did you
research how many people did he actually
know they're like mice and I no one
knows oh [ __ ] that I wouldn't people I
would have those people in my house and
it probably costs him like at least a
million bucks because he has a catered
open bar full staff it's insane and its
house is enormous they're like you need
a full staff and security so I my
impression that he didn't know many of
the people there no because when he
showed up finally because we didn't stay
for very long all the people start
mobbing him in like hey I'm just some
random guy maybe you can hook me up with
some [ __ ] or whatever anyway that was my
impression
regardless I'm this is the setting and
I'm walking around I'm just like oh what
the this is a wild team I go downstairs
and there's a super bright red Mustang
it's like a collectible that he's got
inside of his house and next to this
super bright red Mustang is standing
Logan Paul without thinking because I
thought it would be cool like I just
thought it would be like happy-go-lucky
I approached him and I says hey Logan
what color is that car
laughter the the the glasses yeah yeah
this is well after yeah my god and I was
like I guess I didn't think that it
would be offensive but he I was really
surprised he did he was like oh man
gonna be pissed I'm Victoria like he
already hates me whatever yeah anyway he
seems like a decent whatever he goes he
says to me this is a problem with
podcast you end up talking all that [ __ ]
but you gotta embrace it well I just
said tell did that I'm telling the story
to summarize I'm not summer I'm already
in with too deep anyway it's not like
that crazy yeah now we're building up
yeah
so he goes to me and he says I
fantasized about what I'd say to you if
I ever met you because I want to shake
his hand and he went with my hand and he
was even winding up in a way that was
kind of threatening and scared was he's
a really big guy yeah he's got some
monkeys massive and so he wouldn't shake
my hand and he's like I fantasize what I
would say if I ever saw do if I ran into
and I was like wow what was it what what
would you say to me because Here I am
right and he what was it something done
laying on my face like it would start
vlogging and then put you on a spot
where like here's the guy who made fun
of my disability I'm telling that and
then something about I have pubes in my
face
yeah which is good that's a good one is
that his home I had really close that
see that's really interesting because
personally I have no problem with Logan
like at all like in fact I've actually
been on a shoot with him and I he turned
out to be like a wonderfully nice guy
just kind of like a he's very much of
the YouTube mind set designer yeah
exactly like he's of that mindset of
like anything anywhere hey whatever it
takes to make the video which in half in
my mind I like I gotta respect it
because he'll okay he hustles for it but
I don't know him personally so I was
just gonna put out a disclaimer yeah
super hard-working guy yes I think he's
talented he's a good actor nothing
personally gets the guy I'm not like I'm
not throwing the gauntlet because he'll
be the she'll kill me
[ __ ] have you ever seen that he can kill
you while doing the splits yeah
yeah exactly and vlogging you want to
tell ya wall down yeah givers next to
someone so massive and you're like I'm I
am helpless if this guy just decided to
kill me he's got that going for him at
least against me he's got that aura he's
got that going for him so anyway and he
was like yeah idle boy like he's from
Ohio's with like me early from mission
Matt Cameron we talked about that way
back when so like I can't just help he's
so young - yeah but he's so young
that's why I hate how long did that's
how you like why you gotta kinda black
because I said it did some really stupid
[ __ ] that I'm glad
like I wasn't flogging back dude if I
had this level of success which isn't
that high at 20 I would make a absolute
fool of myself
yeah well I don't even think I'm capable
of having such as I read the Business
Insider uh article where they followed
him around no well now what came from it
whoa whoa whoa what I mean I love where
that it's just it's just really good
reading anything I said bit uh book
notes it yeah yeah I okay so uh one
quote something like he said yeah I'd be
cool with like two to three million a
year my kid said very like nonchalantly
and there was gosh it was it was a whole
thing it was a gay follows there were
like a day in a day in Logan Paul's life
yeah and then he's going to an acting
class where he is
you know goofing off and trying to you
know he's not serious about you know
whatever he's doing and it just it's
good reading yeah I I found some insight
and then dude it almost reads like a
sketch I'm finding well it's got some
real good quality stuff well I'm
definitely have to check that out yeah
it's yeah but the the Viner phenomenon
is something like they invaded youtube
yeah it's just the Viner invasion and
tell them are really talented i think
yeah oh yeah yeah absolutely later
there's plenty of talent floating around
it's just about there are the ones that
hustle way too hard and they may not I
can never admonish someone for reaching
high like shoot as high as you can like
go as far as you want to go but just
don't be an ass about it like on the way
and not saying like Louis man asked ya
here and there maybe but like I just
if Logan's watching out there hey yo he
and he's I agree I agree I agree I'm I'm
good I goofed on the gun but you know
he's he's okay my but he hasn't done
anything wrong he's not like put in a
trump car in a black neighborhood and
like had all these people come and beat
it up yeah like people you get mom
saying no no clearly is clearly a very
hard worker
yeah he's sorry it's just like the
phenomenon like we we outside of our
YouTube personas are all just individual
people and it's weird that a podcast
setting is like the place where wheel
can become the most human and like talk
about it on a real level and like that's
like the great equalizer from all of us
from just stepping back and being like
hey this [ __ ] YouTube thing's kind of
weird huh how about that Lane and that's
what I always marvel and yes there are
clearly dicks and total pricks that even
outside of YouTube they're just a theory
[ __ ] but as a few it's rarer than you
think
oh yeah they're just like a total piece
of [ __ ] person yeah it's really rare
that somebody can Ollie Turvey that's
ago I think generally everyone wants to
be like loved and appreciated and see
themselves as a good person yeah and
that's your size sociopath yeah like to
to the audience's pleasure uh most
people on the Internet are very pleasant
people like there's only like a there's
there's only like a couple people I've
met where I'm like oh your piece of [ __ ]
but like everybody else like very very
nice I'm not really good at going I
think it just comes from like an
appreciation for just what we do and
like we're all so grateful for this
thing that that just happened to us like
we didn't try to make it happen here
like it just happened and so we're just
grateful normal ordinary people yeah
not somebody that was like a child actor
from yeah the age of five that was you
know yeah that's true I don't know if
I've ever met a youtuber who was like a
total dick have we you know it's always
the opposite like we always made people
and then were like oh they're so nice
yeah just not a bunch of normal ass dude
yeah me neither
I don't know more yeah
I the only person I met that I wish
death upon my college like I want to
know about this person yeah we revisit
them if it was their final wish no no
can I can I hear about this guy you have
to say the name it's just anything with
even all right why don't you look at me
like dad built it up in my mind but the
one thing the one thing that can really
describe what made it the worst and what
made me hate him like I was up until
that point I was his roommate like other
me and he's like it was it was fine
whatever he was a little annoying here
and there but like it was fun I was in
college and we had a class together and
we were working on a group project and I
projects by the way bring out the worst
yeah so I couldn't attend the group
meeting that we had because at the time
my stepdad is disabled and at the time
he was in between nursing homes we had
to take care of him for a few months at
home and take caring care of him meant
like walking him to the bathroom not
having him a sponge bath so it was real
intense and a night that they wanted to
meet up I had to take care of my dad or
my stepdad and I messaged him and I was
like hey can can I like catch up with
you guys tomorrow or something I have to
take care of my stepdad and he's just
like no if you're not here you don't get
to be any part of the credit and it's
just like were out of the group okay
dick and I and at first I was like oh
okay he doesn't understand the situation
here so I explained it my step that is
disabled I have to take care of him
literally we have no one else it is like
and then like he just came back with
another like really really like
dismissive but rude super rude like no
no you're just lazy and I was like you
don't know what lazy is and then I got
really mad at him I sentiment angry
texts and they just responds with lol
you mad oh that point on he is dead to
me I wish him nothing but harm someone
that you had interacted with yeah I was
his roommate oh boy yeah your way okay I
miss that he's your roommate yeah mm-hmm
Wow we it was he he wasn't a youtuber
though he's no this was before
just a random person wished death yeah
he was an engineering student with me
yeah and he had the goal after getting
popular on YouTube to send me a message
on facebook saying hey I know we haven't
always seen eye to eye but can you
promote this yeah yeah you probably were
like I've waited for this moment yeah
thought about what I was going to say I
didn't take that road I just ignored him
yes the best that's the best route yeah
Wow that's it I also have a college I
don't hate this person I was more just
like really disappointed and
disillusioned in humanity when I was in
college I had like this was like my best
friend and middle school in high school
we were super close I loved this guy man
we went to college together from high
school we went to the same college and
he started drinking and when he started
drinking became like a completely
different person like he was a sweet
great wonderful friend and he just
became an absolute monster he was the
biggest [ __ ] douchebag and a chip on
his shoulder all the time but I put up
with it we lived together we lived in a
house with four of us and he was just a
real pain in the ass he was a nightmare
but we put up with it because we were
sober he was sweet he drank every night
turned into a monster
whatever yeah anyway came to this point
I was I was dating a really insane girl
at the time she was I guess I didn't
realize how nuts she was she was bipolar
and like I know previously she had like
psychotic breaks but the time I was with
her she was relatively fine anyways my
21st birthday I was drinking and passed
out and then this guy I've known my
whole life he slept with my girlfriend
on my 21st birthday whatever that's and
like I'm like okay whatever I did this
isn't a girl I wanted to marry and I
already hated him so I was like whatever
this is fine just [ __ ] you guys so I
confronted about it and this is when I
lost my mind
he's sober by the way when I confront
him and I'm like why did you do that
that's [ __ ] up and he goes he says to
me if your girlfriend wasn't such a [ __ ]
then then that wouldn't have happened
oh I know like are you a real person
and that I think that was a that was one
of the last times I've talked to that's
like like a really bad line from like
like a like a frat movie yeah like we're
like right here that I'm like American
Pie or something like he'd be the
villain yeah we think that's unrealistic
yeah exact it was surreal because in my
mind I'm like I know this guy so is the
absolute piece of [ __ ] and I hope he
doesn't say something to me like that
because I'm going to lose my mind and he
and he said that [ __ ] you know he's dead
now
did you trick him so um he's not dead he
did almost die incidentally he became
addicted to cocaine and alcohol and he
almost he had like a hole in his lung
because he almost died he was so
unhealthy let me [ __ ] [ __ ] on this
guy I don't care I could say his name
but I'm gonna [ __ ] on him he was so
unhealthy that he went to the hospital
and they said do you have AIDS because
he his body was so unhealthy and so they
drilled a hole in his lung that he had
for like years and his dad came I went
to visit him once and his dad was like
how could you let this happen to my son
I was like out of here you should have
said well if your son wasn't such a
slide in my movie scenario yes the
perfect combat yeah they always get man
that [ __ ] brings back memories play
anyone else I got a person they hate on
that level I'm not the only one I've got
yeah he's only one I've got I don't even
hate him right
just like how how could how I don't know
yeah there's nobody that I hate so much
that you know I wish death upon them but
I think I think not a lot really affects
me anyway like I'm just gonna like
alright yeah like you're a dick okay
I'll just write you out of my life yeah
fine like yeah it's a nice thing and
I've been working on that
it's the joys of being an adult you
don't have to put up with other people
[ __ ] like they're giving you [ __ ] you're
like okay well I just won't talk to you
and my life is better for it I think
that it's something that people don't
even think about in a way it's like you
can just not talk to people you don't
like
it's that simple and usually like if
you're like I feel like I'm like a
amateur psychologist by the way no no no
degree never taken a psychology class
twice but I feel like a lot of times
like if you're having like a shitty time
you're like why am I always like feeling
like garbage like sometimes you just
have to kind of look around and who
you're hanging out with who you're
associating with like if you're just
around a bunch of [ __ ] Downers you're
not going to be the most positive person
that's so true I found it to be the
truth in my life like how many time
again like you really become the product
of your environment I found that to be
true forget when you hang around with a
bunch of shitty people you just act like
an [ __ ] or like really like when I
was a kid and middle school was friends
with like real smart like ambitious kids
and that was like I was like a great
student at that time and when I went to
high school I was hanging out with like
stoners and I became a piece of [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's kinda interesting it's
real amateur philosophy ler there you go
what else
oh gut notes did you guys know that all
diviners live in Hollywood yeah all your
delighting right are on a street clothes
line yeah I always look at that sunset
and vine yeah yeah they live on a street
called vine all diviners in the same
building no yeah I don't know I do truly
I swear to you I think they're slowly
starting to light up just spread out
yeah now that they have you know there's
really a lot of money you're all rich to
buy a mansion but that's not cheap there
no no not at all but the great part is
don't disability I don't believe yeah a
real show out of it really they almost
had a shows like Rainn Wilson canonical
or whatever in Wilson my gut yeah
did you know Felder though because uh
one of the Finers was accused of rape no
rape
yeah hello ray yeah that's fine yeah you
can well actually he still he still has
a successful with it uh you're not a
cute I am no no yeah he was a key I
think he he settled out it was like rape
accusation
his girlfriend who was i curtis lepore
i don't know yeah yeah okay seven uh
several years ago but but it was a time
i think where was like all his comments
were like rapist rapist and then he had
to like you know blocks everybody but
but I think he's doing fine now but yeah
the the place where all the fighters
live the greatest part is whenever you
drive by there you will at least for a
long period of time you always see a
person on a hoverboard always look
around that block you would always see
like two like buff boys on hoverboards
we're just riding down the line street
yep oh yeah I love well I don't love
VidCon no no offense everybody like that
runs VidCon like I love VidCon for a
certain reason but one of the weirdest
things about VidCon is seeing like the
perpetuation of that side of YouTube
come across exponentially more than any
other place what's the hoverboard part
likelike the Viners coming in or like
that style of videos and like those well
I know your timeout rape stuff yeah cuz
I've heard so yeah wait what
I don't know you know I don't I don't
know what I don't know any specific
people but I heard like yeah you know
there's people with impressionable fans
that show up to these things yeah if you
were real scumbag you could do some
weird frankly our Boateng not doubt it
like I don't know of anything happening
but just like it's the circumstances to
create like if you're yeah do your
shitty person you have the ability to
control very impressionable people yeah
but yeah yeah good competition you're
bringing it down like are you guys going
to VidCon yeah I've never been there my
first our first year Lou I've never been
there I don't know what like it's
probably cuz nobody wanted us there yeah
we when I'm invited I only went there
after they started doing the heavy
security stuff and like separating the
youtubers like very very stringently
right last time I was there oh is there
on stage in the middle of the floor with
jacksepticeye and we just got done oh
okay
no I just I'm just picturing it right
picture and Jack yeah
that's all thank you I mean hey we are
we were in the middle in a booth and
then we had to get back behind the back
curtains and it was like a 200-yard like
- and it was chaos I've never like I was
scary
it was horrifying well like I don't I've
never considered myself to be like a
celebrity or anything like that but in
that moment VidCon in the moment was the
first time I ever realized like oh my
god am i celebrity and then like oh my
god I'm a celebrity I have to run later
run we had to run and there were
security guards over like shoving all
ideas and like they're Beyonce on
fencing as if it'll be Beyonce's
horrible horrible I wouldn't wish that
on anyone
good God anyway good are you probably
bad but all the other parts are great
yeah my kids were climbing on fencing
like demonic zombies and world war
season no really it really is like that
because I remember like like whenever
like one fan would like spot a youtuber
they would scream and then suddenly that
one youtuber that one fan it's like a
zombie calling to his friends yeah like
you literally see a shifting mass of
like preteens and teenagers screaming is
that runs no.1 teenagers at VidCon
pretty mostly yeah yeah interesting yet
but I got a I got a like we we did I
mean great last year and I got a lot of
vapenation oh really yeah what a lot of
kids want to do the vapenation Oh No
so how that's just like the photo pose
that yeah like this the default photos
the meet and greets are nice though I
love them Ingrid yeah there was this one
girl during a meeting greed that got
little too enthusiastic she didn't know
her strength she tackled me or a hug Wow
I fall to the ground later I did because
I like and it's totally fine if you're
if you're watching this is fine I find
lovely a little softer next time but she
elbow into my gut like to her shoulder
into my gut BAM I felt my back pop and
like and I was like I have to lay down
and I just literally I'm it's a girl oh
thank you can someone give me
painkillers but I finished that meeting
great Wow but yeah if the main groups
are cool and the panels are really cool
we've got a sense of that in Sweden we
did our first half and that was not
though I saw the photos I wasn't it was
pretty nuts we had that moment we were
trying to escape out the back
and people came around the back and it
was like kind of like this moment you
described where you're like trying to
push through a crowd to a taxi and it's
a little freaky yeah and then when we
took off people were like chasing the
car at first we thought that we knew
there was still people waiting outside
so we thought we'll just leave and kind
of talk to them on the way out and just
walk back and it was so not the case
it wasn't Pepsi cans and [ __ ] Jamie Lee
through my plate they're like don't
leave so they got like a soft
no because they brought it away them one
of our old names is like about Pepsi Max
God so they brought Pepsi Max cans and
then they were throwing it at us and
we're like this is nice but unsafe it's
good yeah act like full cam yeah looking
Oh
like it was a lightly lie ended up
catching one but I quit here yeah it was
just yeah but you you probably had some
really weird fan reaction like
interactions I feel like cuz you have
some pretty like your fans are involved
boy yeah I'm really lucky to have like a
really dedicated really really
enthusiastic fan base as far as like
weird interaction goes thankfully I
haven't had too many like close
encounters but um but the weirdest is
always just people that treat me like a
god and like I want to be around me at
all times
and but that's as weird as it gets it's
usually just conversation really hey I
wanna be alone now can ya can you please
leave me alone but everything else has
been sweet I seen in the comments that
your some of your fans get like really
nasty to your girlfriend yeah that's
just a byproduct of like having a
relationship on the Internet it's that's
gross but I guess no continue oh you
said we never have that we started
together but also nobody wants to [ __ ]
me
which way you don't need to come out in
front of this fact long ago that peace
with my other with my with my and uh
nonsection field trust me I'm gonna be a
hot little twink though but by the end
of this year yeah you get a new trick
like I'm trying to get some soup out of
me yeah
try try and this is me not advertising
it like I like this is but try Kido yeah
like I say clearly no carbs
hi fat no carbs leaves a high fat like
yeah of it because okay this is where
I'm going to get real sciency about
Aikido stands for ketogenesis
ketogenesis is your bottoms biblical it
almost is so ketogenesis is your body's
natural ability to break down fats
through ketones which are proteins that
are specifically designed by your body
to bring down fats and it's it's when
you only eat fats and you get the
majority of your calories from fat and
you get protein as well just to keep
your muscles up your body gets used to
producing ketone bodies and breaking
down fats so when you don't eat
especially when you sleep if ketones
throughout your system and you just
basically run off fat training your body
to run off fat now I wouldn't recommend
this for everybody because it sucks it
sucks it's awful I hated every second of
it I'm not doing it anymore because
frankly I lost too much weight too fast
I walk ten pounds in two weeks and I
don't have that much weight to lose so I
stopped it because it was crazy but it
works so whenever I'm trying to lose
weight I definitely cut out the carbs
that I've never done like the fat the
aggressive that part but carbs when you
cut out carbs it's it's crazy it's that
yeah that's crazy
those carbs will get you by E yeah I'm
so hard though it sucks so much right if
you don't realize how much cost I don't
give a [ __ ] about look like what come on
I don't like pasta now like bah okay I
got it I get how you deal with this guy
I know all he wants is a burger and
pizza I like a practically pizza is
practically pasta just like it's better
that is poss-eye
aureus [ __ ] and it's not worth the
calories let me break it down just like
you utter doodles no I don't like any of
it pasta is like slimy flavorless noodle
wrong what about lasagna lasagna get
down was that so but I would never order
it at a rescue lived in New York I'm
sure there was like good pasta there
right yeah there is it was still under
plan I have a so while it we had pasta
we try to use we try baby - fine you got
bread sauce cheese in the perfect
proportion
there's no winning here guys hurt
feelings
alright these are the hard one man pizza
Eli doesn't like pizza it freaks me out
okay what thank you guys
Oh commence with pot not liking possible
I like reference but I think it's a
product of ethan eating too much pizza
that I thought not to like it
I like it sounds anyway like once once
in a few months this is gonna sound like
a really ignorant question but was there
a lot of pizza in Israel yes I don't I
actually I had my favorite pizza in
Israel and I still think it's the best
one I do tell in fluent in and the other
oh my goodness man it's the bestest
place in this weird little [ __ ]
neighborhood you never expect it right
I've Trevon new New York I've been to
Europe I've been all around the globe
you Pizza everywhere the same
go to this place in Florentine what's it
called ela what is it phone whatever
it's like never located it's the it's
this rare kind of place where it's like
it's never open you go there the clothes
they open sometimes it's like 3 a.m. is
run by the SEPA
just set bait run by this old guy he has
a motorcycle it's a weird place but
whenever they're open there's a line out
the door they have this they have like
this butter has so that they brush on
the crust super thin and they get it to
this point where you know in Brooklyn
they make this thin piece and it's like
a it's like a noodle
I'm not [ __ ] that [ __ ] this guy's got
that thin crispy I've gotten integrity
okay and they had this insane like
garlic pesto brush and he uses a
paintbrush and you see him you're like
oh okay anyway we use that [ __ ] a
checker cheese it's not really in the
Hannibal artists you can tell you're
talking about Picasso you're this other
guy too and is like it's got the coolest
motorcycle it's really funny yeah yeah
all the IO it is much I gotta kill me I
am nice I know I'm good we all got to
get some loot let's just [ __ ] go
there right now just any playin yeah
you're like you're like a deep thought
about I guess and this podcast good good
we've been too much because anything
else love to talk about you guys that's
always tons of stuff what else I hate
talking about myself
totally tell me about yourself mark is
starting a tour yeah oh yeah yeah we're
doing it to her I that's actually what
we just came from actually I just came
from this I was taking improv lessons
from ninja Brian's wife who is Rachel
Wecht she's the funniest person I've
ever met in my life
Wow unbelievable hilarious and a great
teacher of improv and so we're doing a
tour just this summer and I'm not trying
to promote it you see it or not I don't
I don't care like it's going to be good
or bad but it's going to be fun yeah and
that was the whole point of it like we
wanted to have fun with a tour and we
wanted to create a show that was like
something that's actually a little like
spectacular like a little higher
production ball right and something
that's going to be fun you got out there
and meet your fans you can put on a
little show yeah and exercises
I've been practicing improv for like a
year and a half and I have no idea if
I'm actually funnier so because when
you're practicing and you're in a room
with your other friends that don't laugh
at your jokes and get mad oh you feel
have that problem I feel like be funny
with improv right and that's pro but
what then you try to art yeah you're not
trying to go for the joke and improv
you're trying to make funniness out of
like reality or whatever it is it's all
[ __ ] but you know it's but when
you're just doing improv with your
friends and very few people are laughing
so having that crowd there like just to
either be totally silent and I'll be
like okay I'm not funny I get it all
right never doing this dance not for
just there is a laughing yeah whether
it's super maybe or they do it they're
going to they're just going to enjoy
seeing you there yeah okay
it's just you being there with you
enough you could do like we did at the
beginning of this podcaster stare at the
camera burn our half and they'll just be
like yeah yeah that would be that's very
really fun though I hope so
like it's really the old reason was for
meeting up like it have fun and going to
tour with my friends I work with my my
friends from Cincinnati that were there
with me since the beginning of my
channel like they were there helping me
on this small series that I did back
when I could drink coke drunk minecraft
and it was just really fun too
member why we started making videos was
just for fun right for no other reason
than do that's very cool yeah yeah we
we're also planning it to do a live tour
incidentally with the same people yeah I
mentioned they're working with you
oh right angle right yeah yeah right and
yeah seem like nice people they're
pretty good yeah the preview I mean I
have mark aid so anyone else I have no
judgment just like Logan tell your good
model so it's just like well it's just
this thing weird that agent recommend
I'm like okay well if you say so
yeah they've done right by me so far
don't what I can say for ya yeah and the
chat is asking if anyone here has got a
ghost story oh my god bless on a last
episode with the filthy Frank and
postman moment we got into this crazy
ghost story I'm very skeptical I don't
have any close encounters with ghosts
but post and and George has some wild
ghost stories yeah looks everyone's
silly do you guys have any ghost stories
that's got to be like the thing we ever
get no yeah leaving ghosts first of all
high level no no I don't either one of
you I didn't until I loved a friend of
mine um
sees a lot of them okay he's like this
he's like the Bruce Willis just kid yeah
and it was the worst reference ever and
it's like it's it's it's [ __ ] creepy
and like obviously they don't enjoy it
because it's very unsettling and
sometimes they say like they see just
like sometimes we'll see like a part of
a person or it'll be a shadow but
there's one specific one let's go that
so they lived near a really old cemetery
like really old because they're not from
California so you know cemeteries they
go back several hundred years and they
they were in their bed and they saw this
bright light they look out the window
and there's this child just standing in
the driveway like wearing these like old
like like old-timey clothes like
eighteen hundred's clothes we got early
nineteen hundred's clothes and then just
like and then the kid just like looked
up at them and they were like what that
[ __ ] just like closed blinds right
that's crazy
same time no next the the no year same
date an exact time what happened again
same kid what do you remember the date
no he'll do some research but they but
they were but they're saying like yeah
and sometimes that they'll appear like
during during like certain times of the
day like there's more during the certain
time of the night she's the kid from The
Sixth Sense yeah person yeah I was like
do you ever do you ever like talk to
them [ __ ] no like you don't want to
invite that but I never I never believed
I never believed them before but then
like you see the rational reason yeah
see that's the thing the truth felt like
I've never had an encounter yeah I mean
when I see how passionate convicted
people are about it but I kind of do
want to have an encounter you know I've
never it would really bend my whole
understanding of the world yeah I got
one thing it's not really a ghost thing
but it's just something that I I could
never really explain it was when I was a
child so it might have just been the
mind of a child
I have wondering like that as well I I
was I was sleeping you know I was I was
dreaming and up until that point it
what's weird is that my dreams were
never that incredible I had a lot of
waking dreams I have a lot of waking
nightmares to this day like I have
waking nightmares like once a week in a
lot of neighbors you mean like what is
waking night waking nightmares is when
you feel like you're trapped in your
body at sleep paralysis yeah sleeper L
is that - yeah I'm it's a yeah and then
job people shadow people in the doorway
sort of thing oh my goodness when I was
a kid I was having this dream that
somehow instantly like a switch got
flipped and ulsan I was being chased I
didn't know how I didn't know why I was
being chased and I just ran was
perfectly normal dream and then I turned
around and looked and there was this
huge lumbering guy with a chainsaw like
just chasing after me and I knew he was
going to kill me and cut me up so dream
whatever I wake up totally
fine and I I look up above my bed and I
just see his face ah here and pull the
covers over my head I can't when it's on
my cup when I'm under the covers I can't
see not there blinking eyes not close my
eyes not there pull the sheets down
still there no story Martin glaring over
me I've had stuff like that where I wake
up from a dream and then I see stuff and
my theory on that is that like when you
wake up you start like that residual
dream chemicals in your brain so you're
capable of like really intense
hallucinations for like a short window
after you wake up or even before you're
about to fall asleep it's true sometimes
I'll wake up and then I like grab my
phone or something and then I'll kind of
remember something that wasn't true you
know like yeah like you kind of cry I
don't know you're just out of it yeah
you're out of it you're not completely
awake there's like a couple there's like
a couple other stories that that I have
from other people too because I want
here live like yeah yeah so like because
our movie our YouTube read movie was
like a ghost random movie so like I just
offhandedly asked some people in the
crew like oh you guys let me go stories
and like one person they saw on to it so
like on two separate occasions they saw
the PERT like it was like their mom like
they like woke up and their mom is like
floating above them well had her mom
pass but I'm like literally like right
for like she saw them and then they got
a call that same thing happened to their
friend before they got a call yeah oh my
like spooky a [ __ ] and then there's that
yeah then there's another one I thought
this one was in a ghost thing I got
goose pimples
yeah it really would be they say all
right there's one of the worst glee club
like that the person was like staring
down they look very like content and
they said that that was like that was
like actually like strangely calming for
them huh-huh but uh but then this other
one Shane who's a guy in our cast when
he was 2 so he doesn't remember any of
this stuff but basically he fell into a
pool
and he was drowning and he's actually
pronounced dead for a couple minutes
right mom
I don't get that how can you die you
don't you don't you don't I know I've
heard that all the time people like oh
yeah I died for five minutes
Kent dot you don't die for your heart
stops yeah well you're technically then
death is a very strange definition death
Mina see ya like y'all but if your heart
stops that just means your heart stop
there's a difference right there they're
stages of death like there's death to
where the point the body cannot be
sustained there's brain death there's
cell best there like after you die so -
do you not mean your smell you later
well I mean because you know I think
about typically if your heart stops then
the blood blood stops flowing to your
brain and then you die after you're like
a few minutes oh you're dying guy yeah
my god body carries on for a little bit
just a little like brain activity that
no no brain like the rozier body stitch
everything keeps tickin yeah well anyway
he fell and he fell identity yeah he
fell into the pool he was drowning his
parents were having an argument or
something in the house they were gonna I
think there may be like a apartment
complex or there's like a pool in the
middle is something like that anyway
they're having an argument and mid
argument the mom hears a voice like
shout his name and she just drops
everything and runs out to the pool in
season like drowning so there there's
nobody else there like they were talking
and she heard a voice shout his name and
that something was wrong when she ran
out there that's crazy
that's nuts I wish I really wish that I
could not get it have a personal
experience because I feel like I'm such
a skeptical person yeah me too about
religion and about ghosts and all this
[ __ ] it really like blow my brain if I
ever encounter something like that yeah
although I wonder who knows if it's
ghosts or if it's like people are like
well you know like you die but then
there's still like energy you're you
know who knows who knows what exactly it
is yeah my thing it's something I don't
feel like I'm you know I think we don't
know everything yet know me so yeah by
any means that's true but I feel like I
would think that I was going crazy I
got to blame myself before I be like Oh
ghosts you're like to that right yeah
like your brains faulty you're
hallucinating yeah I'm a doubter myself
like I would just I would like be like
oh what's going on here come on yeah
who's got the machine right right yeah
so I would love to have like a real
encounter with the ghost
I would love to yeah convince me
convince me ghost me and me and uh
Austin post alone we're talking about
because he's like a real true believer
and so we want to tell him he's had some
he had some great yeah yeah he's
personally has some really great stories
that you shared with us we want to go to
like a spook like a haunted spook house
like a real uh no not yeah I feel like a
lot of times those are [ __ ] though
it has to be right and all those ghost
shows I feel like most of the [ __ ]
because I just have to force something
and play that stuff yeah yeah most
likely yeah yeah cuz one of the guys on
our Smosh games channel he was a
paranormal paranormal investigator so he
like actually like his moonlighting job
that's what he did back before like the
lol stuff so he would be like the guy
with like the machine that would like
read the Electra meant electromagnetic
electromagnetic Wow electromagnetic
field area
yeah the spook signal and he said that
most the time there was nothing but then
there was like some other times I was
like oh no like some shit's like there's
some weird [ __ ] but he's oh [ __ ] the
heels as [ __ ] ghost stories to like
it is in his apartment yeah like just
like they saw a guy in their closet what
and just like what weird freak eyes was
it okay can i is it a cool okay
the people who believe in ghosts see
them it seems like all the time like I
have so many ghost stories they're in my
closet they're in my car
it's him both him and his girlfriend
they corroborated story yeah like there
is a time it wasn't even they didn't see
anything it was like this chain on their
fan like it was sitting in it something
was like like somebody hit it but you
see what I mean it's like you see it's
like the same people seeing all the
ghosts and meanwhile none of us have
ever seen goes personally but it's the
people the same people seeing all the
ghosts yeah I mean who knows maybe some
people have a sense for it to sense
thing nor they have a stick - a lot
anyway I'm waiting for my for my first
encounter I'm open to it
yeah I'm not really actually I'm really
not open to it at all
I would fight it I think it'd be pretty
clearly right well I'd be like I'm
insane I have no interest in seeing a
ghost yeah I guess what are you going to
do you're just going to freak the [ __ ]
out and it goes away my main problem
with ghosts is the idea that all of
these dead people the billions and
trillions of dead people are just
hanging around in the same space just a
sheer density right what that is and
it's only of people in the most recent
period like where the ancient ghosts
where's the like BC ghosts where are
they - Gus at where the cavemen ghosts
yeah we've never been there have been
maybe that traps in their own time
period that doesn't make it right
doesn't move when you're a ghost what -
okay I don't want to offend again I'm
leaving this [ __ ] well it's like time is
a it's a prospectus Eve time like we see
it as a line but really it could be
where you can live in every moment
simultaneously if you perceive it as
like a fourth dimension like we see
space so it's possible that the ghost
lives in its own dimension of time a
thing that someone could say no it could
be an idea there you go you've
officially lost let's go no no I I get
what you're saying yeah but it is like
it's from a general general standpoint I
totally agree that we would be ignorant
to say that we have everything I would
be ignorant versus I have to say I knew
everything but also at the same time is
like we have some logic and we have some
ability to understand the the what
happens in the universe like to some
extent that maybe ghosts plan maybe not
but yeah I won't eliminate it yeah yeah
I feel like if there's so many people
that have seen it like this like well
not like as you like everybody's
you know I mean like I've written one
but yeah it doesn't hurt me for other
people to believe in goodnight I'll I
love to debate it's interesting but like
for example I I'm like agnostic about
God do you believe in God
uh because yeah way more people believe
in God and then goes yeah right but
these are of course a lot of people have
visions of Jesus and everything too so
I'm saying like well as people see
visions of ghosts I mean I guess it's
not really too too different from what
people have seen like when they say like
Oh
like God came to me last night they're
gonna hear you know so who knows hmm
yes I just feel like people people
search for answers for everything they
see in our lives because in the end we
are walking bags of meat and but you
know we we we try to rationalize
everything that we see and you know
people find comfort and answers they
want answers and be nice enough if
someone you loved passed away be nice to
be like hey they're out there and
they're trying to tell me what up so
whatever you find comfort in so long as
it doesn't hurt anybody else oh you
gonna fall for that right here go for it
I do have one story oh I do believe in
ghosts
okay when I was a kid I don't know if it
was a ghost it may have actually just
been a really creepy thing that really
happened I was laying in bed and right
across from my room there's a window
with a curtain and I usually close the
curtains but on this day it was it was
open it was about 5:00 a.m. the dawn had
broken it was just a little light out
and I like I'm opening my eyes and I see
a [ __ ] face in the window staring at
me and it's like a real creepy face it's
not like a normal man's face it's like a
Freddy Krueger kind of Jason face and
it's just staring at me peeking in and I
my heart starts racing I'm freaking out
and then it that whatever it just walks
off creepy it could have actually just
been somewhere yeah that's the big like
it's not paranormal in fact
like not not worth my time sorry kids
not going so early guy those late is a
human contact I wish that your good
looks
Ethan and then six years oh yeah oh this
is what you're yeah I was gonna [ __ ]
back here oh all right huh I guess you
can't run again oh I know that yeah it's
so good it was a good exploration of lot
of issues they would cover a lot of
ground
yeah well the Holy Ghost Yoga favors
such a little joy child sprinkle in
there for no measure
it was really great having you guys it
was a lot of fun I genuinely respect you
guys both flaw and appreciate you both a
lot I thank you for coming to join us
really you guys are all seeing eye I
really love what you guys do
and I'm really really happy that you got
this whole like studio set up here this
is really cool it's better than any live
stream production tonight oh yeah oh man
to say I'm so glad that that you guys
you know found this from just your
that's a 10 video that's on the
beginning yeah until Thursday all 3
watch that after you done so good that
was like I had that was a weird
realization psionic continuous color
sounds just like a weird realization
like years later when I was like wait a
second holy [ __ ] that Ethan I sampled
that video without real second on you
and I'm going back to credit note like
that's so cool it was back in a lot of
useful balance that it's so fun I think
it's super cool I mean it's like I had
two life separate lifes that we're both
like meaningful really cool we used to
make just video edits but we're like
this is really fun and it's artistic and
I enjoy doing it but people just they
come and they go like you guys had no
idea was us and I'm blaming because it's
very transient it's like that was a fun
experience but now I'm not going to
stick around see what else is there so
we realize we had to make live action
stuff we had to do something with like
some personality yeah and so we stopped
doing that because we realized that
people were not remembering who we are
it's kind of a proof-of-concept you guys
didn't know the humor was there like
from the get-go as expressed in that
video and then I'm just really proud to
see you guys out there
thanks appreciate that it's it's it's no
it's sick and I was watching your [ __ ]
back then you're a god you are like The
Godfather yeah and you're how long's
been ten uh eleven and a half
god damn eleven and a half I know well
how old were you when you started or
seven I was seventeen ten that's crazy
Wow Wow people weren't even making money
on YouTube back then no no we were we
were packaging our own shirts and
mailing them out ourselves
that was one source of revenue was was
our crappy like screen printed shirts
that we had made by a guy with one leg
in a warehouse down the street okay he's
not as it goes but uh yeah it's so crazy
to even think about because when I think
of like um my brother he's been doing a
webcomic for I think nearly fourteen
years now holy really and when I think
of like people that have the longevity
of that and maintaining that my brother
still to this day is cranking out higher
and higher quality comics every single
time on his what is it it's called two
kinds it's this webcomic that he's been
running for a while it's how do I
describe it even it's about t TW o ki n
des yeah pretty much yeah that's what it
is yeah but I just I just really respect
like the work to put in and especially
like on YouTube the harsh field of
YouTube so yeah yeah the ups and downs I
don't leave it like today is my
five-year anniversary I collect random
internet yeah but uh it's just crazy to
imagine I've been doing it less than
half the time anybody like forever right
yeah and I we think yeah yeah we then
we've seen people through like from like
middle school to graduating high school
it's like weird stuff like that they
want to really grow up with your fans oh
yeah yeah yeah and also like it's also
like you know you guys obviously I'm
sure deal with it it's like oh I miss I
miss the old day we've been busy
pretending
here one year old we can tell we're new
on YouTube because we just started
getting about like six months ago
congratulations you guys all the time
but it's cyclical so like I'll get
people will be like always getting back
to the old one and then the people that
like the old one we're like oh I don't
like [ __ ] everyone stand you're yet 50%
zero always angrier you just gotta do a
site very specific like videos where
it's began and ended there being good
that happened yeah or like very soon we
did like 2014-2015 Smosh was the best
yeah but then in 2014 everybody's like
this [ __ ] man did you know that 8 Smosh
was legit the weird thing about when I
think about like oh I miss the old Ethan
meme is like it's almost like no you
don't like those videos weren't good and
like if I try to recreate them which we
have done they just feel bad well that I
know that you're evolving your content
when you look back and you're like oh
that's garbage now yeah yeah it's just I
don't know people are just complaining
on the on YouTube and everything I made
with gold mark like I look back at my
obit of like oh yeah
just sit there yeah that's what I do i
watch my old videos actually that's a
fact I go back and I watch my old videos
because I like to I like to look back on
what worked and what didn't work it
keeps me grounded in terms of like going
forward and making content some like but
yeah it's all gold I'm great and I'm the
best but it could seriously sometimes I
do watch little videos - and I'm like
man I feel like I was way funnier than
that's not a depressing - it's a
nostalgia thing oh yeah yeah and
obviously you were probably more a lot
more critical of yourself when you first
put that video out also the funny thing
is sometimes I'll remember that when we
made it we didn't think about learning
[ __ ] and I was back and we're like god
this is great yeah it's like my video
you guys ever seen like yeah I know I
put my mouth on a cat yeah yeah and I
spent eight hours making it and in those
eight hours it became the least funny
thing I've ever been it's my fourth most
viewed videos like what in the hell like
and that was range
stupid decision I never should have made
that in yet
now one of my most successful would hold
up you don't oh my god quality editing
yeah I was so tired of dragging my lips
around on a cat after that looks easy
but it's weird like those things that
seem like they they won't work resonate
with the fans incredibly and that's what
always makes me remember like it it
doesn't matter
like if I censor myself before it's done
then I'm never going to know if it's
actually good or not right because I'm
my own worst critic we all are yeah and
then when it's exposed to the people out
there that are actually watching like
putting up with the time to actually
filter through the good stuff like those
gems come through and it's just that's
the most satisfying sense
so something that ya know oh yeah one of
it is short oh but that's the thing that
scares me is like we've had I wonder if
I'm a good judge of my own content so
waste of time
okay well yeah I got there I cannot
won't be embarrassed if you hold on let
me just peep at it yeah just give me
people creep that it's hard to be a
judge of your own content because you're
especially if you're editing it so I
edit it and then sometimes all like cut
something or I'll have like cut
something and then I'll bring it back
big regime in Venice everyone's favorite
part
oh yeah this is a crap then we're doing
what yours is from do you know this was
I just like laughs yeah right good yeah
yeah oh I just oh yeah yeah we just know
like even be looking at out like oh it
was that bad okay low video I know it's
like hi Logan
I'm trying to come up with some way to
celebrate ten million and I
procrastinated and made this I know why
I bother you so much I look back on it
real life very creative to some extent
both my cat Wow why did I waste my life
making this video to queue eight hours
yeah but that's pretty good time I've
gotten faster over time with my 30
million yeah 30 yata 30 million yeah
that's how that works and then I made a
sequel called wolf for that's worth
another one no borders not one dog don't
pay attention of all those like the most
proud of one I'm of those as popcorn
which is a sketch we may would don't
want like it's too long it wouldn't even
be about it but just because like I just
find that YouTube is best when it's at
its heart experimentation and [ __ ]
like you should you just make you make
mistakes unapologetically and you just
shove your mistakes out there and
someone will watch it I feel like we've
kind of lately I feel like creatively
bankrupt to be honest yeah there's just
I don't know man I feel like so stuck
creatively on YouTube right now
like there's nothing less good to talk
about like think about this when YouTube
ad the ad pocalypse a crackdown
everything all the nut jobs they
celebrate on our chatter no longer make
money on YouTube there's or nothing or
there's at the end smart in their
language he's gonna [ __ ] on me yeah a
lot of smart guys they flourish from it
they understand yeah but it's like but
even beyond that it's like okay another
reaction video I don't know I'm
challenging we're trying to think of new
formats new ways to be creative and make
content it's tough yeah yeah it is like
with massage and say there's something
like meow II just know that do some dumb
why are you going to the hump a video
those not more experiments are not
people hated the [ __ ] it
that yeah yeah like a meme it was like
ACH so he's over something like you
don't know until you put it out I get it
and you hear that and you can't huh yeah
okay well this [ __ ] post we were trying
to make a month surface that's more
mangy did any of you guys watch bro
signs life and it all that is a guy yeah
I know but bill stated that meathead who
plays a character yeah funny I love his
videos but for hundreds video he put out
this really highly produced music video
where he was rapping it was really well
done looked great everyone hated it like
it's just not funny hit on yeah well I
loved it I didn't love it but like I I
enjoyed it you were spend we're okay
you're like I was finally oh you weren't
offended that he put in effort to make a
nice video yeah and then everyone hated
it so it's like you never know that's my
favorite when I put all the time and
effort in the world to make a good video
and then people like this is low effort
yeah I'm like well I guess I'm done
trying that was yeah we had a we had
this we did this rap first husband's
Creed 3 it was really successful is
great was sponsored which is plus hello
beloved it and then we made we made one
for Assassin's Creed 4 and like
everybody's compared it to the last one
everybody [ __ ] on it it's like we had
like we had like a [ __ ] pirate ship
like a real like ship that we were like
like sailing in the bay
we're shooting up cannons we're doing
all this stuff we put so much effort
into it
we were like look snow is good as a
sudden through your uh that was probably
like the most deal or like so much time
and money but it was also sponsored
doesn't matter but put a lot of time and
money into that and and it was like yeah
it's really it hurts yeah I mean like
when it happens to me I say I don't know
it's hard not to take it personally I
swear to god being you youtuber before
we were youtubers I was a very calm
rational down-to-earth very right was I
and now I'm straight-up bipolar like I
feel like that every day
like high and lows because everything
happens so fast on YouTube yeah it's
like really tough I think that's the one
benefit that's been keeping me going
strong is I could give
[ __ ] if someone like shits on my video
and I'm saying like I'm better than you
because I think that but it is Loudoun I
don't like that I've always been oh I'm
so self aware of when something I make
is good and when it's bad and I take
pride in the things that I know are good
because the people that appreciate the
things that I think are good are the
people that I want to see that like
they're there the audience it doesn't
matter to me if they're one video that I
put a lot of work into gets a small
amount of views compared to one that was
like that that wasn't really that much
effort and get luggage wasn't the
audience a lot of effort into something
and it gets like a really low amount of
views and people don't like it even like
I'm okay with that because I'm not
saying you should be okay with it also
motivated not harder yeah it's not a
rational basis just like movie I do but
like it's also it's also setting
expectations too because if you're like
if you're like I'm not happy unless the
video gets 2 million views then like
you're just always going to be looking
for that thing that's going to make you
happy but then it's like that goal could
have easily been 3 million or 1 million
in there really matter why that gauge of
your happiness or you know two fresh
apples how you dealt with that like over
the years ah
you ever been in that thing oh
absolutely I mean I think every youtuber
kind of like looks at work yeah I'm
always successful I think every youtuber
looks at like their performance like
whether it's like how many views a video
gets in a day or a winner or monthly or
subscriber counts or all that stuff and
then the moment they see something not
going to their expectations they start
flipping out right and that's something
that you know we we've had to learn over
you know all these years is that you
know things may get better things may
get worse but like we're still able to
do what we enjoy right and you know
we've been doing this for you know 11
and a half years and like we haven't
lost our jobs yet yeah I guess I should
be I should be thankful for that instead
of instead of benchmarking my videos
that's nice how do you guys know and
that's something similar because I do
have videos that will flop and will not
work
and it really uh it really is moralizing
especially when you put so much effort
into it but the the best part about this
for me and this whole adventure on
YouTube is that I never expected to be
like in the top 50 YouTube channels like
I didn't and I'm saying quality I'm
saying quantity like top subscribe you
have like I saw recently you have like
seven billion yeah something what's your
most views on your channel let's finger
down I don't have a billion I don't know
it's it's sometime around there here
pock yet not what I never expected that
so that's one view for every person on
the point yeah but even at the heart of
it like I try not to let that ever like
get to me because I always remember that
one person could be watching and I'd
still love to make videos and and so
long as I have enough money to be able
to make them like I'm I'm really happy
like I'm happy expressing creativity and
finding new ways and and even if my
channel died tomorrow like no one is
going to believe me on when I say this
but even if my channel died tomorrow I'd
be totally fine with that like if all of
my subscribers tanked and none of my
videos gov use it would be great because
I I'm just the type of person that loves
to push and find the new thing okay if
my channel dies been good I have time
free time to actually like pursue and
improve myself and and try something new
so like what time Victorian yeah that'd
be nice yeah
cool I just find it fast
I think the problem with YouTube as
opposed to like other media's is like
the feedback we get is so direct and
immediate mmm-hmm it's like a dress it's
like a you know it's a drug and it's a
poison if you have a show on television
it's like you don't there's no comments
there's no direct interaction if the
show's doing great or it's tanking it's
even also you probably don't hear about
it immediately exactly you probably like
wait and then you see how the whole
season did exactly like that it's not
like a blast of like emotions yeah yeah
I don't know it's [ __ ] it's wild oh
yeah wild ride it's new it's crazy like
yeah I especially like I I'm not saying
I don't judge myself based on how many
likes of videos it gets because I do
like I like I can't help it but do but
yeah I just don't let it like them yeah
smash smash it please if you're
listening now please smash smash the
like button but yeah I just try not to
let it stop me from being creative or at
least trying I need to I mean we need to
get more creative mindset I'm trying
ah go out to like take take a break I
finally took a weekend for my
girlfriend's birthday we went unto
Joshua Tree which is a national park
right near beer idea yeah yeah beautiful
we we would just like do we made sure we
did nothing we film some of our own
stuff for her channel but then just took
pictures but we made sure that it was
all very casual and just like let
boredom taken because boredom is where
creativity comes from like the the need
to do something allows your brain to
actually have that and sitting out in
the desert with no one around and just
looking at the stars on the the
completely empty sky and just seeing
stars forever ever just doing nothing is
the best thing you could ever do for
creativity cuz if you never Aki telling
you leave is goddamn editor Ethan yeah I
more time yeah it's hard it's hard I
have a real deal I have a real troubles
um I do I need I need to you're right
I have a real trouble like giving that
work that's your bayonet workout man
yeah
but I'm not I still edit some of my own
stuff so I can't fault you for that deal
alright
and you would stop it and then anyone
else have any other new threads to
follow with any more ghost stories
anybody that was good look at all
stories anybody can call anyone who
enjoys a story do we sell is every good
I think we checked off all the boxes
those are the three important I think we
covered a lot of ground here today yes
she's how long is this going to be proud
I don't know that's good
we've been running over time no there's
not over time okay just as long as we
can party Miley like good say in
ourselves actor it's America we got to
keep the ghost story thing going yeah
some reason it just it's fast everyone
either has one or know someone yet has
one yeah I don't even know anyone that
has one that's how on ghost story my
life is Wow but now you do
you go now I know someone did whoa yeah
yeah yeah I know somebody knows I got
crazy goes
you know anyone that has crazy ghost
stories I don't know I feel like some
people like even if they had one they're
too afraid to say they did because they
don't want to sound like a crazy person
huh
there's also that too many but it's a
pretty norm it's pretty acceptable to be
like hey I have a ghost story yeah yeah
not anymore
all right let's end this [ __ ]
nightmare okay guys thanks for watching
do you need to plug me undies again
before else no no I